advanced research is the source of
revolutions in thinking and revolutions
in living advanced research is
absolutely necessary to deal in the
complex and integrated world that we
live in planet earth and humanity are
facing an enormous number of challenges
we see things happen around us and we
want to know why did that happen what
we're doing is answering questions that
people ask every day but doing that in a
formal way and if you like filtering out
the answers which are wrong or
misleading or incorrect and trying to
substitute those with ones that take us
further to and deeper into an
understanding of the core processes that
shape our lives I see my role as being
able to bring evidence to bear to these
debates and be able to tell people that
that some taken for granted assumptions
might be wrong and then produce evidence
to show why that might be wrong but also
to be able to answer some of the
pressing questions about difficult
things where we don't necessarily know
the answers we need that knowledge in
order to make rational sensible
decisions about what to do and what
policies have develop and how to move
forward as communities as nations so you
need to bring together the most creative
people you can find in an environment
that is conducive to collaboration
sharing of ideas and and this is exactly
what so far has been able to do see far
is a unique meeting of minds this is a
place where people who have a great
passion for the same question but at
different levels can come together and
discuss their latest findings these are
fundamental questions that if answered
will be transformative to the planet
better health outcomes better societal
outcomes better outcomes for the planet
that we live in and it's the way the
future
you